♪ [Say it Loud, I'm Black and
I'm Proud - James brown] ♪
I think maybe I just wanted
to be a DJ in another life.
I just like playing clips.
The--So this is an excerpt
from James Brown's "Say It
Loud, I'm Black
and I'm Proud."
It's released in 1968.
You know, we aren't quite
there chronologically yet.
I'll be coming, coming up
to it in the course of the
lecture though.
And it becomes
an immediate hit,
a popular hit, and
a political hit.
It's played at rallies to
rev up the crowd and call
and response, certainly.
Brown actually distances
himself from the song after
a handful of years, saying,
"Look, we needed it
at that moment.
We needed it to develop
pride in the black community
to understand who
we were as a people,
but, you know, things
are more complicated now."
This is something he's
saying in the 1970s,
as his politics
start going off in,
in a variety of
different directions.
But we are at this moment,
for the purpose of today's
lecture, essentially '66
through the end of the
six--through the
end of the decade.
We're at this moment of
profound fascination with
blackness in a different,
in a different kind of way.
It's being articulated in
different ways than it was
at the moment of SCLC's
being established or SNCC's
establishment.
We're at a moment of
incred--sort of in the wake
of incredible successes with
the Civil Rights Act and the
Voting Rights Act, a moment
of incredible ambiguity:
what are we going
to be doing next?;
what's the next
step in the journey?;
and a moment of
profound rupture.
I already talked a little
bit about this last week
with--calling attention to a
tone shift and a strategic
shift as far as black
freedom movements are
concerned in the
late--mid to late 1960s,
and we'll deal with it a little
more explicitly today.
One more clip, this one a
video clip, as a way to get
another, well as a way to
get more traction on
what's happening in this
particular moment.
It's a very short one.
Eldridge Cleaver, who
had gained fame from his
writings in prison was the
chief spokesman for the party.
We feel that the police must
be brought under control by
any means necessary,
including through force of
arms, and we have never
bit our tongue about that.
We say it now,
loud and clear,
we will always say it and
we're not afraid to say it,
that the racist Gestapo pigs
have to stop brutalizing our
community, or we're
going to take up guns,
we're going to
drive them out.
I think he made his
point rather clear.
This is a period of
also incredible
rhetorical hyperbole.
I mean, I'm not saying that
he didn't mean these things
certainly, but, but the,
the scope of what's actually
going to happen, the
violence and the rhetoric,
is palpable and we are
certainly past that moment
of the beloved community,
with Martin Luther King and
his dream in 1963.
And we'll talk, depending
on how far I get in today's
lecture, might start talking
about King's final years
today, or we'll certainly
pick it up on Wednesday.
But you'll see the
unraveling of this beloved
community, especially when
we start talking about King.
Now you saw a clip there
about Eldridge Cleaver,
Minister--Minister of
Information for the Black
Panther Party.
Let's back up a few steps,
overlapping where we were
last Wednesday, make sure
we're all on the same page
about the Black Panther
Party's establishment in
this moment of the
Black--the Black Power
moment in general.
You remember that I
talked about the
Lowndes County Freedom
Organization in, in Alabama,
the Lowndes County
Freedom Organization,
the first group to embrace
the black panther as a
symbol.
Stokely Carmichael, a
veteran of Mississippi
Freedom Summers
and freedom schools,
just out of
college essentially,
SNCC activists--activist,
goes down to Lowndes County
where he discovers these
farmers and helps them
organize into the LCFO.
Becomes a radicalizing
moment for Carmichael,
one that is on sort of
a steady pace for him,
one radicalizing
moment after another,
that eventually leads to his
exile from the United States
in just a handful of years.
So we're in 1966.
James Meredith, young man,
a civil rights activist who
had integrated Ole Miss, the
University of Mississippi,
the bastion of state
privilege in that particular
state.
If you wanted to become
a leader in Mississippi,
you went to Ole Miss, and
this was a place that was
unavailable to
African Americans,
and James Meredith
wanted to change that.
He integrates Ole Miss
a few years earlier,
and in the process,
residents of the area riot
and actually kill federal
marshals who are there to,
you know, ensure the
place gets integrated.
James Meredith is an
iconoclastic character if
ever there was one, and
actually comes out very much
against civil rights
later on in his life,
saying it was
demeaning that we,
that African Americans
had to still cling to these
notions of civil rights
heritage and battles.
James Meredith decides that
he wants to call attention
to the changes in
Mississippi that have been
very real, certainly, and he
decides he's going to march
across
Mississippi in June of '66,
a March Against Fear.
"No one's going to
tell me what to do.
No one's in
control of my life."
He's marching by himself.
Civil rights leaders,
people on the ground,
friends of the movement, are
el--all telling Meredith,
"This is crazy.
You cannot do this.
Okay, you've done a lot
of great things for the
movement, but the idea of
actually trying to march
across Mississippi
by yourself without,
without protection is
a suicide mission."
It turns out
they're almost right.
Meredith starts off on his
march and before you know
it, he's laid flat by shots,
someone driving by with a
shotgun.
He's hospitalized.
He survives, of
course, he's--but,
but it's not clear at that
moment what's actually going
to happen.
Leaders of the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee,
SCLC, CORE decide,
"Well we're not going to
let--Now we're not going to
let this march fail."
So they set out to complete
Meredith's march against
fear, so they're going to
march across the state.
At a stop in
Greenwood, Mississippi,
Stokely Carmichael,
now the leader of SNCC,
been thrown in jail for
I think the eighth time,
I believe.
They'd done the jail,
no bail strategies.
The march is still going on.
Stokely Carmichael gets
out of jail and tells an
assembly out on the lawns,
"The only way"--excuse me.
"The only way we're going
to stop them white men from
whipping us is to take over.
We've been saying
'Freedom' for six years,
and we ain't got nothing.
What we're going to
start saying now is 'Black
Power.'" And it's
call and response.
You know, "What
do you want?"
"Black Power!"
"What do you want?"
starts going
through the audience.
Now Carmichael wasn't the
first to start calling for
Black Power,
using that phrase,
but he popularizes it, and
so it becomes attached him.
People had been ruminating
over that phrase and sort of
throwing it around for
months at that point,
but this is one of these
sort of lightning flash
moments, where it captures
the national attention and
also scares the nation.
King heartily disapproves.
It's like, this
kind of, you know,
calling for this kind of
militancy is misplaced.
The country is at sea, and
we're going to alienate all
those people who might be
fellow travelers in this
journey with us, by this
kind of--with this kind of
anger.
I mean sure, we
can be angry,
but this is not the path.
So you take together the
Lowndes County Freedom
Organization and
its rising profile,
Stokely Carmichael
being on the ground there,
Stokely Carmichael and
others taking up the March
Against Fear after James
Meredith has been shot.
Carmichael
essentially snapping,
saying, "The hell with this!
You know, trying to do
things through the system is
only getting people
shot without retribution.
We need Black Power.
We need to stand
up on our own."
You remember whites had
been now thrown out of SNCC.
They no longer have a
place in the movement.
In October of
that same year,
two college students at
Merritt College in Oakland,
California, Huey
Newton and Bobby Seale,
formed the Black Panther
Party for Self-Defense.
The Black Panther
They'd been
hearing about the LCFO,
thought it was a
fantastic idea.
They'd been seeing
this radicalizing moment
happening in
SNCC, and they say,
you know, "It's time for us
to take our stand on our own
terms.
We need to embrace
Black Power as well."
Huey Newton declares himself
the Minister of Defense of
the Black Panther
Party for Self-Defense,
and Bobby Seale
is its chairman.
And I just realized,
[laughs] I left what I was
going to read at home.
Anyway, it's a good
thing it's in your reader.
The, the, at the
moment of their founding,
the issue of the Black
Panther Party platform,
it's a couple of pages
long in your reader.
I can't read the
points I was going to read,
but the fact is
essentially this.
I want you to look at
that particular document,
and look at the kind of
things that the platform is
calling for.
It's calling for the
kinds of fundamentals,
for lack of a better phrase,
that I've been calling your
attention to from other
freedom organizations since
the Niagara
Movement in 1905.
Now it's calling
for more than that,
of course, but it's still
calling for fundamentals.
This is the state
of the conversation.
It seems to not have
changed in some ways.
Now it has changed in the
sense that the Black Panther
Party is,
through, through the,
the platform, and then what
you're going to see later in
the Executive
Mandate Number One,
talking about in a
few moments here,
is connecting African
American freedom struggles
to what's happening
on a global scale.
It's clearly
Marxist in its ideology,
in its political--its, its
understanding of political
economy.
It's viewing its struggle
in the light of what it
considers United States
imperialism in places like
Vietnam.
It's being motivated by the
kinds of militancy that you
see black soldiers coming
home from yet another war,
still being denied
their citizenship,
but now the ground has
shifted enough that they can
articulate themselves
in a different way that,
that is calling for
armed self-defense.
It's not about, you know,
trying to get in the front
door of a bus or the
front door of a restaurant.
It's about something
much larger than that,
about being a
global citizen.
Well, as the Panther Party
is organizing itself and
delineating in
the, in the program,
in the platform the ways
it shall be organized--no
you're not going to drink,
you're not going to do
drugs, you're
going to, you know,
be respectful in all
different manners of life,
and whether they succeeded
in that or not is a whole
other kind of conversation.
The Panthers start
looking for a way to grow,
and they hear about this
guy named Eldridge Cleaver.
Eldridge Cleaver,
thrown in jail--I'm sorry.
My notes seem to be all
over the place today.
It's fascinating--thrown in
jail and then writes this
book Soul on
Ice, and becomes,
you know, is
incredible--incredibly
charismatic and
quite brilliant as well.
The Panthers realize
they can actually tap into
Eldridge Cleaver
and his charisma,
and they use him as the
Minister of Information.
That's how you saw him
speaking to the public in
his position as the
Minister of Information,
trying to spread the
narrative of what the
Panthers were all about.
Now the popular notion
of the Panthers is highly
masculine, these young
men representing the,
you know,
manhood of the race,
they're very virile.
They've got their
black leather jackets,
they've got the
berets, their turtlenecks,
very fashionable.
There are some women in
the Panthers as well,
but, you know, where they
fit into the movement at the
early stage is really
a little bit unclear.
Panthers are armed.
They're going to take back
the streets under their own
terms and take control away
from the "racist pigs" as
they refer to the cops.
The Panthers would do--the
bases they were in Oak--in
Oakland at their
founding--decided to take
control of that
community first,
and very
contro--controversially,
one of the tactics
they decided to pursue is
monitoring the police.
Just as you see
people in Los Angeles in,
at the flashpoint of the
L.A.--the Watts riots,
excuse me, people frustrated
by the years of police
brutality, unmarked,
unchecked police brutality;
Oakland residents
felt the same way.
And so the Panthers
start to patrol the police,
it's the famous
Panther Patrols.
They studied the California
laws to the letter,
and they knew that they
had a right to carry guns,
and they knew that they had
a right to watch the police.
And they knew that if the
police arrested somebody,
they could stand witness, as
long as they kept say twenty
or thirty feet, I
don't know the distance.
As long as they kept
distance--the proper
distance from the
police, they could observe
everything that's happening.
Now as you can imagine, if
you're a police officer,
whether you are a racist
pig of an officer or not,
you're not going to be too
thrilled about angry men
with guns following you
around when you arrest
somebody, whether they
deserve to be arrested or
not.
You're not going to be
too happy about that,
because the guns are loaded.
It creates
incredible friction,
and creates a crisis
at the state capital.
The Panthers--the
state legislature,
very unhappy about
these Panther Patrols,
entertains a bill that makes
it illegal to carry weapons
in urban districts.
Well, the Panthers
were exclusively urban.
Now it didn't mention race,
didn't mention the Panthers,
but it clearly was
targeting the Panthers,
trying to kill
these Panther Patrols.
So the Panthers decide
to go up to Sacramento,
the state capital,
and challenge the bill,
and while they're
there, something of a circus
happens.
I want to play to you--for
you a clip of that circus.
The boldness of the Panther
actions attracted young
blacks, many in their teens.
Carrying loaded firearms in
public was a well-protected
legal right in California.
But with the emergence
of the Black Panthers,
state officials introduced
legislation to outlaw
carrying loaded
firearms within city limits.
May 1967, in protest
the Panthers traveled to
Sacramento, the
state capital.
We arrived there, all
these black men and women,
twenty-four males
and six females,
with guns and Ronald
Reagan, then the governor,
was on the lawn with two
hundred future leaders of
America, you know, twelve
and thirteen and fourteen
year old kids.
And these kids started
leaving this session on the
lawn and coming to see us.
And these young white kids
thought we were a gun club.
Knowing the media
would be there,
the group of men and women
then entered the capitol
building.
They're heavily armed,
whether their weapons are
loaded or not,
nobody seems to know.
Wait a minute.
Am I under arrest?
Am I?
Get your hands off me
if I'm not under arrest.
If I'm under
arrest, I'll come.
if I'm not don't
put your hands on me.
Is this the way the
racist government works?
Don't let a man exercise
his constitutional rights?
I'd like to make a statement
now with this respect.
Statement of the
Black Panther Party for
Self-Defense.
On the Mulford Act
now pending before the
California legislature,
the Black Panther Party for
Self-Defense calls upon the
American people in general
and the black
people in particular,
to take full note of
the racist California
legislature which is now
considering legislation
aimed at keeping the
black people disarmed and
powerless at the very
same time that racist police
agencies throughout the
country are intensifying the
terror, brutality, murder
and repression of black
people.
A nation that had grown
used to the nonviolent civil
rights movement was now
confronted with new images
of black protest.
Later, at a
Sacramento service station,
news cameras documented the
continuing debate over law
and gun.
Ain't no sawed off,
that's a riot shotgun,
just like yours.
Do you all know the
constitutional rights?
Sure we do.
We're well aware of the
constitutional right -- You
have no right to take
my gun away from me.
You breaking the
constitutional rights.
The pamphlet says that
the Black Panther Party for
Self-Defense calls on the
American people in general
to take careful note of
the racist California
legislature.
Why do you believe the
legislature is racist?
Don't you know?
You're a part of it and
obviously this is a white
system.
This is
obviously where we at.
Do you believe everything
that's in that pamphlet?
The pamphlet
speaks for itself.
As you see, people didn't
know what to make of these
young men and young women.
The Panthers go national
immediately following this
run-in at the state capitol.
People are attracted
to the charisma of its
representatives,
its members.
They're attracted to
the cleverness in the way
they're handling, you know,
the police and authorities
that don't know what
to make of these folks.
But they're also responding
to the agenda of the Black
Panthers, and certainly
in, in no small measure,
internationalism.
I want to read to you an
excerpt--and you heard part
of the Executive Mandate
Number One being read.
This is what they came
up to Sacramento to,
to announce.
I want to read to you
a, a longer excerpt.
"At the same time that
the American Government is
waging a racist war of
genocide in Vietnam,
the concencra--concentration
camps in which Japanese
Americans were interned
during World War II are
being renovated
and expanded.
Since America has
historically reserved its
most barbaric treatment
for non-white people,
we are forced to conclude
that these concentration
clamps--camps are being
prepared for black people
who are determined to gain
their freedom by any means
necessary.
The enslavement of
black people from the very
beginning of this country,
the genocide practiced on
the American Indians and the
confining of the survivors
on reservations, the savage
lynching of thousands of
black men and women, the
dropping of atomic bombs on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki, and
now the cowardly massacre in
Vietnam, all testify to the
fact that toward people of
color the racist power
structure of America has one
policy:
repression, genocide,
terror, and the big stick.
Black people have
begged, prayed,
petitioned, demonstrated,
and everything else,
to get the racist black
power structure of America
to right the wrongs
which have historically been
perpetuated
against black people.
All of these efforts
have been answered by more
repression,
deceit, and hypocrisy.
As the aggression of the
racist American government
escalates in Vietnam, the
police agencies of America
escalate the repression of
black people throughout the
ghettos of America.
Vicious police
dogs, cattle prods,
and increased patrols have
become familiar sights in
black communities.
City Hall turns a deaf ear
to the pleas of black people
for relief from, from
this increasing terror.
The Black--The Black Panther
Party for Self-Defense
believes that the time has
come for black people to arm
themselves against this
terror before it is too
late.
A people who have suffered
so much for so long at the
hands of a racist
society must draw the line
somewhere.
We believe that the black
communities of America must
rise up as one man to halt
the progression of a trend
that leads inevitably to
their total destruction."
Again, an era of
heightened prose,
certainly, but there's no
doubting that the Panthers
are tapping into a
nerve that's reverberating
throughout America,
deepening anxiety of what
exactly is going
on over in Vietnam,
deep concern about what's
happening to the young men
who come back shell shocked,
if not in body bags.
Now so much of the Panthers
is about this bravado,
so much of the Panthers is
about actually doing real
work on the ground.
And over the
course of the, of the,
sort of the, the heightened
moment of the Panthers'
existence, which is really
about '66 to about '74 in
terms of its
greatest coherence,
the Panthers are doing
other things as well.
Yes, there's no doubt that
there are many Panthers who
are violating the, the
Panther program because they
were using alcohol
and using drugs.
They were also
selling drugs and,
you know, en--engaged in
all kinds of things that are
illegal.
There's no doubt about that.
This is part of the
thing that infuriates white
America.
It's like, "Why are we going
to let these thugs have guns
for goodness' sakes,
and, and tell our police,
our right-minded
citizens, what to do?"
But the Panthers were also
doing things on the ground
that people really
didn't hear about,
or if they heard
about it, they ignored.
Looking at a
city like Oakland,
with essentially a ravaged
social services system,
the Panthers saw the need
for after-school programs
for black children and
for hot breakfast programs,
things that they just
weren't getting through the
school system.
So as the Panthers get
a little more organized
towards the late
sixties and early seventies,
you see hot
breakfast programs starting,
after-school
programs starting,
you know, basic education,
literacy kind of programs
starting as well.
You also see, not
just in Oakland,
but in places
throughout the country,
with a ranges of success,
Panther health clinics
opening up.
These are medical
underserved communities.
And even though we're the
era of the Great Society,
when, when LBJ is trying to
prop up the poorest people
in the country
across the board,
the quality of healthcare
in black communities was
abysmal.
So the Panthers
organized health clinics,
free health clinics.
You come in--and very
successfully organized
sickle cell anemia tests,
a disease that afflicts
African Americans
disproportionately in this
country, and the
Panthers would test for it.
And try to find,
to help these,
these people who get
tested positively,
to get the medicine they
need to live a life without
so much discomfort and pain.
So the Panthers were
doing social service work,
community
organizing work, certainly.
They were, in their way,
trying to enforce law and
order, follow
the constitution,
state constitution as well,
and they were also doing
those things that
terrified so many Americans,
in terms of representing
this kind of angry,
violent, hyper-masculinity
and also being involved in,
in gun and drug trades.
Now Eldridge Cleaver had a
particularly important role
in cultivating support for
the Panther Party and does a
lot through Soul on Ice, the
book I've asked you to read
this week, or read
most of this week.
Cleaver is, was,
a petty criminal,
and if you've
already started the book,
it's, you know, shocking
that here's a person who
admits to rape and
justifying by prac--or not
justifying, explained that
he practices on black women
before his plan to
start raping white women.
He is, to be as
polite as possible,
rather homophobic.
He goes after James Baldwin
in most aggressive ways.
But he's also, he's
also quite brilliant,
certainly as a
cultural commentator,
cultural critic.
And I want to read a passage
from the book that actually
helps you understand, or
gives you a sense of the
ways in which that Cleaver,
through Soul on Ice,
really fascinated a certain
well-heeled part of black
America--excuse
me, of America,
that really helped the
Panthers onto the road of
success, at
least for a time.
And I believe this is from
about page one hundred and
seventy-eight.
It's essentially, I think,
maybe three sentences I want
to read, but it's one
heck of a series of three
sentences.
"In the swift fierce
years since the 1954 school
desegregation decision, a
rash of seemingly unrelated
mass phenomena has appeared
on the American scene,
deviating radically from the
prevailing hotdog and malted
milk norm of the
bloodless, square,
superficial, faceless,
Sunday morning atmosphere
that was suffocating
the nation's soul.
And all of this in a nation
where the so-called molders
of public
opinion, the writers,
politicians, teachers and
cab drivers are willful,
euphoric liars or
zip-dam ostriches and owls,
a clique of
undercover ghosts,
a bunch of Walter Jenkinses,
a lot of coffee-drinking,
cigarette-smoking,
sly, suck-assing,
status-seeking,
cheating, nervous,
dry-balled,
tranquilizer-gulched,
countdown-minded,
out of style,
slithering snakes.
No wonder that
many innocent people,
the manipulated
and the stimulated,
some of whom were game for a
reasonable amount of mystery
and even adventure, had
their minds scrambled.
These observers were not
equipped to either feel or
know that a radical break,
a revolutionary leap out of
their sight, had taken place
in the secret parts of this
nation's soul.
It was as if a drive--it was
as if a driverless vehicle
were speeding through
the American night down an
unlighted street toward a
stone wall and was boarded
on the fly by a stealthy
ghost with a drooling leer
on his face, who, at the
last detour before chaos and
disaster, careened the
vehicle down a smooth
highway that leads to
the future and life;
and to ask these Americans
to understand that they were
the passengers on this
driverless vehicle and that
the lascivious ghost was the
Saturday night crotchfunk of
the Twist or
the "Yeah, Yeah,
Yeah!"
which the Beatles
high-jacked from Ray
Charles, to ask these
Calvinistic profligates to
see the logical and
reciprocal links is more
cruel than asking a
hope-to-die Okie music buff
to cop the sounds
of John Coltrane."
It's a heck of
four sentences,
and really one of the
sharpest cultural critiques
that I've seen in
quite some time.
Now, taking back to the very
beginning of this course,
when I talked about the
ironies of John Jack's
existence.
Remember, the, the charcoal
rubbing of the headstone,
saying that you
couldn't understand,
you know, American freedom
without understanding
slavery.
You might
remember, I forward--I,
I shot forward two
hundred years to talk about
Eld--excuse me,
Ralph Ellison,
saying that southern
whites could not talk,
sing, walk, make love, or
make war without thinking of
blacks.
Eldridge Cleaver is
doing the same thing here,
in a very different
voice, very different voice,
mind you.
But he's telling about this
moment of fascination of
white America,
progressive, left-leaning,
white America
especially, with blackness.
Part of that fascination
grows out of the martyrdom
of folks like
Malcolm X, of course,
Medgar Evers, Emmett Till,
but it also grows out of
this anxiety about what we
are as a country during the
Vietnam era.
It grows out of an anxiety
that you see reverberating
through radical left groups,
largely white groups like
the Students for a
Democratic Society.
So the Panthers are
tapping into a nerve.
In fact, a lot of their
funding comes from white
progressives, who are just
completely enthralled by
what they see as the brutal
honesty of the Panthers.
Now building off the
Executive Mandate Number One
incident in Sacramento,
building off of the
popularity of Soul on
Ice, the Panther Party goes
national, starts
building itself,
its, its social
service organizations,
its clinics.
But this is not to say
that things go smoothly.
In fact, the Panthers are
one car wreck after another,
in a sense, as far as its
organization's concerned.
In October of '67, Huey
Newton is arrested in
Oakland, during a dispute
over which a cop is shot and
dies.
He's thrown in jail and
you start having "Free Huey"
rallies popping up
all over the country.
The phrase "Free Huey"
is in response to this,
knowing he's been
thrown into jail.
The facts about the
case were murky at best,
and actually in three years,
he's released from jail,
with the charges dismissed,
something that horrifies
law-and-order types.
But while Huey
Newton's in jail,
the Panthers want to
see, they need to feel,
they, they, they recognize
the need to build upon this
trajectory, upward
trajectory of popularity,
and they reach out to
SNCC, Stokely Carmichael in
particular.
And they offer Carmichael
the position of Prime
Minister of the
Black Panther Party.
You know Carmichael's got
this magnetism that's got
people excited
about Black Power.
He is being seen by many
people across the political
spectrum as the heir
apparent of Martin Luther
King and Malcolm X, although
of a different kind of
politics, but
the heir apparent.
The Panthers see SNCC
as a great resource,
because of
Carmichael's charisma,
certainly, but also because
SNCC has proven its chops.
It has organized and
organized and organized and
has a national structure
already in place that fans
could, you know, build
into that structure.
SNCC, through
Carmichael's thinking,
sees that they can tap
into this sort of this heady
moment in the Panthers, and
their international agenda,
and build something great.
The problem, however, is
that Stokely Carmichael,
in a sense, violates the
premise of SNCC that had
been there for so long, of
group-centered leadership.
He was the head of
SNCC, but you just,
you know, he didn't actually
consult anybody in SNCC
about this affiliation.
So other SNCC leaders and
people on the ground are
really, you know, angry.
Yeah, they kicked
whites out of the movement,
so you might think
they're really on,
in, online, in line
with the Panther ideology,
but there's no consultation,
so they're upset about that.
And, as it turns out,
because the Panthers were so
open about courting white
support--through cocktail
parties, where Eldridge
Cleaver would come up and
tell, you know, all the
whites in attendance about
how bad they are,
essentially--because the
Panthers courted
white support,
SNCC militants said, "We
have--We've left whites
behind.
We don't want
anything to do with it."
So the irony is, you know,
the way we historicize a
group like the Panthers
who we hear a lot about,
is that, you know,
they're the most militant,
you know, race nationalist
group on the scene.
And SNCC, whom less is
well known about the group,
of course, but it
turns out that SNCC,
which starts out
as this, as this,
you know, very polite,
respectable group of college
kids, white and
black, committed to voter
registration
drives and leadership
organization--leadership
development,
they says, "To hell
with all of that.
Whites are out.
It's about a black agenda."
So the coalition
collapses, and in,
and in short order,
Carmichael is essentially
forced out of SNCC because
he's now gone far afield of
what SNCC has
actually--has become.
So the Panthers--now we're
in early 1968--are trying to
make sense of themselves
as an organization.
Over the course of the
next five or six years,
they implode time and again.
Huey Newton develops an
incredibly damaging drug
habit and as the nominal
leader of SNCC starts
purging people.
He kicks out Bobby Seale;
that's one of his first
targets.
Huey Newton, you know,
coalesces power around
himself.
He's purged
people left and right.
It's almost like, you know,
these stereotypes of this,
of a demagogue
gone a bit crazy.
Eldridge Cleaver
leaves for exile.
Seale is disillusioned;
he's left the Panther Party.
You have battles developing
with other grassroots
groups, like the
group called US,
based out of--essentially
based out of UCLA in Los
Angeles, under the
leadership of Maulana
Karenga, a cultural
nationalist group that wants
to align with the
Black Panther Party,
but the Panthers
are internationally,
politically nationalist,
not culturally nationalist.
And there's a gun battle in
Westwood on UCLA's campus
between the radicals and
US, the group called US,
and the Black--members of
the Black Panther Party.
And then seeding discord
this whole time as well are
external forces, like
especially an FBI program
called COINTELPRO,
Counterintelligence Program,
COINTELPRO.
COINTELPRO started, I
think, in the fifties or so,
as an
anti-counter--anti-radical
group, but really gets
focused on the Black
Panthers more
than anybody else,
any other organization
in the late sixties.
The task of COINTELPRO
was to infiltrate the
Panthers--they were trying
to infiltrate everybody,
but really focused on the
Panthers--infiltrate the
Panthers,
spread lies, rumors,
and discord and watch the
Panthers destroy themselves.
It turns out they were
awfully successful at it.
The Panthers, as they
uncover one informant after
another, or one suspected
informant after another,
start to implode
in places, in,
in Detroit, in Chicago,
all throughout the country.
No one could be trusted.
It didn't help that
Huey Newton is sort of
drug-addled as well.
This most amazing moment
for the Panthers' existence
really is short-lived,
two or three years,
before this really starts
to happ--starts to become
unspooled.
And actually, we can
get into the 1970s,
women are
running the Panthers,
and that's when there's the
most success with the school
lunch programs,
these after-school
programs--school lunch--hot
breakfast programs,
excuse me,
after-school programs,
and health clinics
really take off in the early
seventies as well.
So these are a number of the
events that take us through
the late 1960s and into,
into the early seventies.
By '73, '74, the Panthers
are essentially defunct.
There's still chapters
around throughout--I mean
they never--there hasn't
been a moment when there
have been no--there hasn't
been a moment--I'm trying to
think this through double
and triple negatives here.
There have always
been Panther chapters,
since the
Panthers were organized.
And you have Panther
chapters now called the Gray
Panthers.
You know, these are
folks who are now,
you know, sixty and
seventy years old,
who have not given up on the
militant--militant attitudes
and progressive critiques,
who are trying to organize
themselves.
But the--it was a
flash, a moment in,
in time, a brief moment,
with the Panthers as sort of
this, this group that
claimed so much fascination
with the American
public and fear as well.
Now in talking about
the Panthers in this way,
'66 through the
end of the decade,
I've left out a whole other
narrative that's really
quite critical, upon which
the Panthers are sort of
based its foundation.
It's really a
narrative of the North.
The Panthers are
overwhelmingly an urban
group, organization and
a northern and western
organization,
based in Oakland,
but, you know, you can see
them through urban enclaves
throughout the
northeast, Midwest as well.
This is a moment in
the late sixties,
heading into the
early seventies,
of, as I said,
confusion and dismay.
And it's a moment of Martin
Luther King taking up the
final battles of his
life from '66 to '68,
as he takes the
movement north,
the movement--SCLC
takes it north,
to engage in new battles.
Fame--Most famously, he
takes the battle to Chicago.
And that's what I'll
actually spend most of the
lecture on,
discussion on, on Wednesday.
But I want to maybe
wrap things up here,
it's a couple of
minutes early actually,
with a reference to a
poem that might frame this a
little bit.
It's a poem by
the late poet,
Gwendolyn Brooks,
one of the great,
one of the great
American poets.
She writes a poem
called "We Real Cool."
When asked about the
poem--this was written in
1966.
This is why I'm reading--I'm
bringing this up now,
I'm sorry.
When writes about the
poem--when asked about the
poem, Brooks had the
following to say: "I wrote
it because I was
passing by a pool hall in my
neighborhood in Chicago one
afternoon and I saw--well,
as I said in the poem,
seven boys shooting pool.
And I'd wondered how
they felt about themselves,
and I decided that they felt
they were not quite valid;
that they certainly--that
they certainly were
insecure.
They were not cherished by
the society and therefore
they would feel
that they should,
well, spit in the face
of the establishment.
I used the month of June
as a symbol--as a symbol,
an establishment symbol,
whereas the rest of us love
and respect June and wait
for it to come so we can
enjoy it, they
should jazz June,
derange it, scratch in it,
do anything that would annoy
the establishment."
This is Brooks's poem.
It's very short.
We real cool.
We Left school.
We Lurk late.
We Strike straight.
We Sing sin.
We Thin gin.
We Jazz June.
We Die soon.
It's a poem that starts
out with an assertion of,
you know, cool
aesthetic that we would see
reverberating
through the Panthers,
certainly, that quickly
moves through the despair of
living in an inner-city in
an African American enclave,
caught up in
drinking and games.
Caught up in an
anti-establishment ethos,
as she mentioned in
describing the poem,
but then ultimately
caught up in a moment,
a language of despair
and of hopelessness.
"We jazz June.
We die soon."
Although King doesn't
know that he's going to be
assassinated, what you see
in the final two years of
his life, someone who
was truly establishment,
Martin Luther
King, certainly,
you see in the last two
years of his life sort of a
reckoning with the
intransigence of certain
problems in the North that
create a mindset where you
have young men who
are hopeless in the
possibilities
for the future,
and of course,
like the young men,
he too would die soon.
And we'll pick up that
narrative on Wednesday.
Thank you.